this wasn't the arrival the world's
number one men's tennis player had
planned on the eve of the australian
open
whisked off to a government quarantine
hotel with his visa revoked on touchdown
immigration authorities said novak
djokovic had failed to meet the
requirements to enter
there are no special cases
rules are rules that's the policy of the
government and has been our government's
strong border protection policies and
particularly in relation to the pandemic
that has ensured that australia has one
of the lowest death rates from covert
anywhere in the world
tennis australia and the victorian
government had granted him a medical
exemption to travel to melbourne to
defend his grand slam title but the
federal government deemed his
application insufficient with reports
the visa he used to try and enter
australia did not allow for exemptions
for unvaccinated travelers
the abf has done their job entry with a
visa requires double vaccination
or a medical exemption
i'm advised that such an exemption was
not in place and as a result
he is subject to the same rule as anyone
else dokovic has never publicly revealed
his vaccination status but his
opposition to vaccinate is well known
his medical exemption to travel to
australia triggered widespread anger
from many who've endured months of
lockdowns and his covert 19 infections
reach record daily numbers but his
supporters are furious with the serbian
president labelling the incident
harassment and maltreatment declaring on
social media that his country will fight
for novak truth and justice
he's got the massive serbian community
behind him
and we all love him and um can't wait to
actually come and support him and see
you playing is that thank you australia
for locking down like a refugee like a
criminal thank you so much novak dokovic
had been seeking to win his 21st grand
slam singles title overtaking rafael
nadal and roger federer at this
tournament for now those hopes seem
dashed instead he's facing a legal
battle to try and stop being sent home
sarah clark al jazeera queensland
australia